all right humans of the internet
this is the reuben report direct message
for october 8
2020. we're going to be doing vp debate
reaction and reaction to the reaction
and then you can react to that
we'll also be talking about how donald
trump has now announced that he will not
take part in the next debate because
they just announced basically out of
nowhere
that they want this thing to be virtual
so this just i saw this this morning
and uh i have some thoughts on that and
i think he's probably
sort of kind of making the right move
but there's definitely some pitfalls on
that
uh and then third i want to talk about
the movie industry which is in complete
absolute freefall and regal movie
theaters which i'm sure you guys have
all been to regal movie theaters when i
was growing up we would
go to the regal triplex uh they are
closing like 500 locations
it sounds like temporarily for now but
they're they're uh furloughing
40 000 employees the movie industry
obviously is absolutely
imploding like many industries and and
it's a sad thing and and now they've
delayed some
some major movies we'll get into some of
that stuff but obviously
we have to start by talking about the
debate
and the media reaction to it so first
off i just want to say to you
get get comfortable in your chair uh if
you're watching this
or if you're on a couch whatever you're
on i want you to
really make sure you're like kind of
like in it and you're not gonna fall
because i'm gonna
be doing some mansplaining there's gonna
be some man splaining up
in here because that apparently is a
thing if you are a man
and apparently you react to a woman in
any way you are
mansplaining you are somehow
misogynistic
and by reacting to a woman
you are automatically mansplaining that
is a new thing i just like to say for
the record
if you're a man and you use the phrase
mansplaining
unironically i'm fairly certain uh
you're a eunuch
and somebody took your testicles and you
should find that person and try to get
your testicles back and then i don't
know who you go to
to get your testicles reattached uh well
i guess a urologist or a testicle expert
um because uh no mansplaining they're
all
saying this these pundits and blue check
twitterati people they're all saying
mansplaining as if it's a thing
as if it's a thing so all right we're
gonna go through a little bit
of the the debate reaction let me just
uh for those of you that didn't watch
my whiskey laden recap last night let me
just say a couple things uh i predicted
that basically all pence was gonna have
to do was not fall out of his chair
because he just needs to show everybody
that he can steady the ship
the trump 74 if he got sick he just had
corona if something happened to him
whatever it might be
that that he's there to just make
everybody
feel like oh the wheels aren't going to
fall off this thing we ain't going over
the cliff i think not only did he do
that i think he actually did a better
job by that and i will say also
that it's not as if i don't have
political disagreements
with mike pence i absolutely have
political disagreements with mike pence
if mike pence was to read
my book don't burn this book mike pence
would come away
thinking that we have some serious
political disagreements mike pence and i
disagree on abortion i'm begrudgingly
pro-choice
i believe that a woman should have a
right to choose for that first trimester
and i go into my explanation on that
in the book mike pence is absolutely
pro-life that is a
massive political difference that i have
with the vice president right
um mike pence as far as i know well
certainly personally is not for gay
marriage and i suspect he wishes
that it was not the law of the land it
is the law of the land i haven't heard
him say one
thing in the last three years that would
imply that he wants to reverse it as the
law of the land and that would also mean
a supreme court decision which would
reverse a
supreme court decision which is
obscenely rare
absurdly rare and also uh you know the
supreme court doesn't take rights away
from people and it would open up such a
crazy pandora's box that i really do
believe
that the ship has sailed on this and by
the way the vice president doesn't
doesn't make
laws right he doesn't make laws the
president really isn't supposed to make
laws either we have a whole
other branch that legislative branch
that doesn't do much but they're the
ones that are supposed to do it but the
point is i have some disagreements with
pence so i'm not sitting here saying
pence is the greatest guy in the world
or anything else
but i will tell you this he obviously is
a competent vice president
um he he did a nice job i thought in
in defending the president but putting
all the
issues aside for a minute he was
completely respectful
of uh kamala harris i don't think there
was a moment
where he wasn't respectful did he jump
in a little bit yeah
did she jump in a little bit yeah and by
the way
it's a debate and what's supposed to
happen in debate these things are
very you know plastic package debates
where i'm going to give you two minutes
to talk uninterrupted and you get two
minutes of talking uninterrupted
and then you can talk for a second and
then you could talk for a second i mean
that's not a debate like
we should basically be doing this as
i've been saying as a thunderdome idea
two men enter or women whatever it is
sorry for the mansplaining
uh two human beings regardless of
genitalia enter
and one leaves that's what we should be
doing with this thing let them battle it
out
we almost don't need rules i would say
to them whoever it is vp debate regular
debate
i would say you threw you guys got two
hours get up there
and you know what you you could have one
rule you need i think probably one rule
which is
you know you can do 15 minutes on this
topic 15 15 whatever it is something
like that but basically no rules and let
them go at it
these pre-packaged things it's it's just
again
it's the end of television it's the end
of media it's the end of old politics
we're watching these calcified systems
that don't really work anymore
and and we're really at the end of it
and i am very hopeful that
four years from now we're gonna have a
very very different world
because i think the media will have
completely imploded i think the the
political system uh in large part thanks
to trump for just driving a train
through the whole thing
will have brought out a much more
interesting intellectually diverse set
of people on the right
and god only knows what's going to
happen on the left but
anyway that that's why i'm hopeful so
they were both respectful of each other
uh well
no i can't say that pence was respectful
of
kamala was kamala respectful of him i
mean there are a lot of moments where he
just tries to jump
in with just nothing like really nothing
like this isn't an angry guy this isn't
a show boater
like is this a guy that you'd really be
at a party with like man that guy is fun
no obviously not he's not there for that
so he was completely respectful of her
she was dismissive of him
and you know with all the eye rolls and
the you know i'm talking now like i just
can't imagine a least likable
uh candidate i just can't i mean
democrats if
if you're watching you dnc people
tulsi that was your girl you missed the
boat you would have brought in tulsi and
a lot of moderates
i think a lot of even conservatives and
certainly the anti-trump people
would have been all about this and i
think you guys really really dropped the
ball
uh tulsi she's anti-war she doesn't
believe the government should absolutely
do everything she's not into identity
politics
i had her on the show we have some
disagreements too but like that was the
road but instead they went with this
like robotic deeply unlikable person and
it has nothing to do
with her skin color or her gender media
matters clipped the thing of me last
night implying that
i don't like her because she's a woman
and it's like you people
are just pathetic losers and by the way
uh
you know when they clip things when
these companies these non-profits
these very well-funded nonprofits when
they go after people
what they're trying to do is get a mob
going so that they can cancel somebody
but i'll talk to you directly media
matters i'm my own boss
i'm my boss the chances that i fire
myself are very slim
what meeting could i have dave you're
gonna have to come in we have to talk
about this and i'm gonna go dave really
you know like i'm not firing myself so
keep it keep it coming though it's good
it's good pr
um anyway i want to go over a couple of
the tweets that i saw
after the debate because they're they're
so ridiculous
that i think they're worth showing
because these are tweets by sort of
legit
mainstream people who put out sort of
the worst set of ideas all the time so
first off i want to put out
a tweet by mark ruffalo and now mark
ruffalo is an actor you know him as the
hulk he was not the best hulk right i
think ed norton was
a much much better hulk and ed norton
actually turned down
the avengers and then they brought in
mark ruffalo and he's just sort of like
this like
i don't know nothingness like sort of
asexual
hulk i don't know there was something
about him i didn't like ed norton like
there's a lot there there's all there's
like
pain and anger and curiosity like
there's
anyway he's just a much better actor but
putting that aside uh
i'm only using this tweet by mark
ruffalo because he's become one of the
most
outspoken progressives in hollywood he
just
took part in that naked video did you
see that idiotic naked video that these
hollywood people came out with and sarah
silverman was in it and chris rock and a
couple other people
and they get naked until you tell you to
vote and it's just like man you guys are
you guys are actual parodies of yourself
you're making fun of yourself at this
point anyway he's become a real
voice and he campaigns for people and
everything else he's a real sort of
lefty progressive
out there voice in hollywood and he
tweeted this after the debate
i thought it was pretty interesting he
said just going
over it all in my head the way mike
pence constantly
interrupted and spoke over kamala harris
was the prime example
of white male supremacy and its common
dismissal
and disrespect for black women
imagine that being your takeaway from
the debate
first off pence was absolutely
respectful
secondly it is a debate so there's going
to be a little back and forth
thirdly i believe all people are equal
so if all people are equal i assume
that's what you actually believe mark
ruffalo
if that's what you believe well then a
white man and a black woman black woman
can have an interaction
and sometimes he's going to speak over
her and sometimes she's going to speak
over
him and by the way that's exactly what
happened
is if anything she was far far far more
dismissive
of him than he was of her but the line
in there that's really incredible is
that he says this is a
prime example this is the prime example
of white male
supremacy now we keep being told we live
in a white supremacy nation that trump
supports white supremacists
that there's a group of people out there
who want white people
to reign supreme now if
slightly and occasionally speaking over
a black woman
is white supremacy well then
i don't think white supremacy is much of
a big deal and i think you don't even
think so mark ruffalo
he said it's a prime example of white
supremacy
but it's nothing the thing is it's
absolutely nothing
it's a debate it's a place where two
people are supposed to argue
if mike pence had said you know i would
like to put a law in place my first day
in office
for trump's first day in office we're
going to put a law in place
that white people will each get an extra
50
in their paycheck that would be an
example of white supremacy
white people are going to have special
laws and white people
are going to get netflix for free that
would be an example of white supremacy
but slightly interrupting somebody every
now and again
while they're doing it to you in a much
more flamboyant fashion
if he's saying that's the prime example
of white supremacy in essence he's
saying yes
everything that we tell you about all of
this nonsense about the patriarchy and
white supremacy and the rest of it it's
all bs nonsense and forget all of it so
anyway there's the hulk
and you ruffalo anyway i'm gonna bust
out a couple tweets here
in a row because the the mansplaining
meme
went out to uh to the masses and they
all kept saying he was mansplaining to
her which again if we are to believe
that men and women are equal
which i obviously believe and i'm
assuming you obviously believe well then
a woman is sometimes going to say
something especially in the political
arena
a woman might say something and a man
might have a disagreement that is not
mansplaining that's called equality
right and you're gonna you're gonna
jostle back and forth about the better
ideas that's how
we get good ideas out there otherwise
what is a debate should every time
uh kamala harris said something should
mike pence have been like
well you are a black woman so i'm just
gonna sit quietly
susan page give her a check mark give
her a gold star for that one
okay so here's a couple a couple tweets
by some some blue check people
first is uh cathy ann she's a filmmaker
she said pence needs to stop
mansplaining dominating and gaslighting
the women tonight there's a lot there
you got my feelings on the mansplaining
part of it but the gaslighting
lighting gaslighting is when in effect
it's
it's a phrase that sort of was born
online because it's the idea that you go
sort of so over the top with your
response to somebody that it sort of it
burns down the whole house
so instead of making like a cogent point
if somebody if you're arguing with
somebody instead of making like
just a sensible point you gaslight them
meaning you just say something
so crazy or so over the top that you've
just destroyed the whole thing
does that seem like what mike pence
quiet mike pence
who barely moves when he speaks and is
respectful and nice and actually looked
at her
um you know did that seem like he was
gaslighting
i don't think so kathy all right dan
rather the disgraced cbs
former cbs news anchor but you'd think
you know
he could probably make a coaching point
the guy's been
you know in the public eye for 40 years
he's covered
countless presidential debates vice
presidential debates
everything else he said i don't think vp
vp pence's mansplaining
and over talking is doing a lot to end
to narrow the gender gap unless it's
also turning off more men as well i mean
there's just so much nonsense in there
the gender gap also doesn't exist it's
it's based on choices you're not going
to believe this but men and women
choose different careers based on
different factors
it's so it's crazy it's crazy it's not
that companies are looking
to go how can we screw the women it's
just not a thing and if you want more on
that i would recommend checking out
a prageru video by christina hoff
summers on the gender pay gap
charlotte climber who's formerly of the
human rights campaign she had a doozy
and she consistently does doesn't matter
she said there is no woman
and i mean no woman who could have done
better than kamala harris tonight
there is indeed no woman including
kamala harris
who is going to win over a certain
portion of men
your male buddies who thought pence won
they don't like women in power
sorry i mean this this type of stuff is
just nonsense first off
correct me if i'm wrong but i'm pretty
sure most men like women
right most men like women they like
having them around
they like being with them they like
having sex with them
they like talking to them they like
dating them they like going out to drink
they like having fun with women so this
idea that men
are running around secretly in hatred of
women
is just crazy right my mom's a woman
love her my sister's a woman love her i
have many women friends like it's just
like
it's just such a what what is wrong with
you people
um but this this okay so your male
buddies who thought pence one they don't
like women in power
sorry this is such nonsense also because
uh i mentioned tulsi gabbard before and
i gotta tell you when i had tulsi on the
show there were a lot of people my
more right-leaning people in the
audience who said you know i'm not i'm
not a lefty so i don't like
you know some of her democrat policies
and she's a little too big government
for me and this that the other thing
but i really like a lot about her i like
a lot about her she
she seems decent i mean just just take
the general temperament
um and i don't mean this as i'm
comparing women to women in terms of
temperament but
but if tulsi gabbard had been up there
the calmness
thoughtfulness decency humbleness that
would have come through
and and kamala harris just doesn't have
any of those things that's not because
she's a woman a man cannot have any of
those things
donald trump is not very humble right um
but all right then one more the abc's
george stephanopoulos who of course was
a bill
clinton former spokesman he worked in
the white house he is now the anchor
for abc news uh and he said
a lot of people were noticing some
mansplaining going on tonight i mean it
really it does feel like they just get
the memo
they just get the memo and and by the
way when they get the memo on
mansplaining that means that the racist
memo just they knew it wasn't going to
work right because what do they want to
do
if you're the average media person uh
what do you want to do
after a white man debates a black woman
you want to immediately no matter what
say that he's racist but it was so
obvious that nothing he did
had anything to do with race which is
their easy gotcha card
that they moved from race to
mansplaining so he must hate women then
yes
he must hate women stupid okay let's
move on to story number two
i just saw this this morning so uh the
debate commission decided to change next
week's debate
uh and now uh it was supposed to be on
october 15th so it still will be on
october 15th
if it is going to happen but as of this
morning uh trump told maria bartoromo
on fox business that he's not going to
partake in a virtual debate because they
decided they want to do this on zoom or
on skype or
whatever um i think there's an
interesting move here now first off it
sounds like they the debate commission
just made this decision
without going to either one of the
campaigns now
i will try to be as clear on this as
possible and as nonpartisan as possible
it's pretty obvious that doing something
just remote
is really great for biden right he can
read the prompter
he can just sit there they see and
here's the here's the tricky part and
this is kind of technical
um but you know when when you do
something online
like this if you need to hear something
you have to have an ifb in your ear so i
don't have one in right now because i'm
just talking to you guys and i don't
have a control room talking to me
but sometimes when we do the show if we
play clips i need to have that ifb
in my ear so i can actually hear the
clip or that my
my director can count me back in right
so he'll go three two one so that i know
when the camera
is back on now the idea that because
they're doing this virtually they're
both gonna have ifbs in
assuming it happens right they're both
gonna have ifbs in but that means
that people will other people will be
able to be talking to biden and there's
just no doubt
that they would use that to their
advantage now i'm not saying trump
wouldn't use it to his advantage too
it's like at that point
if we're going to do it this way then
you don't let your opponent have an
unfair advantage that you don't have so
trump
would probably do it as well but the
idea
that biden would be able to just sit in
front of a camera be fed information
could also be fed information from the
teleprompter
you can look directly into a camera like
i'm doing right now
and they can because the way they do it
now there's like a mirror
beneath the camera basically and so
right now for example although i'm
looking into the camera
i have a teleprompter up all i have on
there is the three things that i'm
talking about today the vp debate thing
uh that we just covered the trump
getting out of the debate story
and the movie theater story so i just
have three talking points and then i do
everything else off the top of my head
but i am looking at a prompter right now
so they could put all sorts of
information there and everything else
so biden's team obviously is totally
down to do this and and trump is saying
no we're not going to do it now
the risk is by not doing it it's like
trump if trump's good at one thing
it's about sucking media sucking
attention
right keeping it all about him all the
time the idea that he would back
out of one is a little against what he
would normally do
but i think you know he's good at making
things work
towards his advantage and i think
showing the nonsense the fact that the
the moderator of the debate is a former
biden intern i mean come on and susan
page yesterday
who was the moderator is writing a
biography
on nancy pelosi it's like this is all so
obvious
their bs is just like leaking out
everywhere
so it'll be interesting to see what
happens i mean you know trump he could
announce the day before that he is going
to do it and then biden will probably
dump out so who knows what will happen
um and for all i know as i'm talking
about this there's more
breaking on the story right now but the
idea if we can't get these two people
into a room
um then it's actually just crazy and you
know what the fact that trump has
already
uh you know beat coronavirus has the
antibodies etc etc
and if you you could double the social
distancing you could do the
the plexiglass you could do everything
else there's no reason
not to do it in person there's simply no
reason not to do it in person
but by not doing it in person you
absolutely increase the chance that
anybody could cheat and anybody could
have info on that prompter in their ear
or in a series of other ways so that's
my thoughts on that
and then i want to do one more that's
not directly political um
it's just kind of depressing actually um
movie theaters are closing all over the
country
and um i want to go through i'm going to
throw up a couple
of the of the delays that are happening
but first off regal movie chain which is
one of the biggest movie chains i'm sure
you guys have one either in your
hometown or
the the city near you they've got uh 536
theaters in the united states they are
temporarily closing
all of them and 40 000
of their employees will now be
furloughed uh
amc and cinemark those are the other two
big movie chains they are not closing at
the moment but basically nobody
is going to movies i mean absolutely
nobody's going to movies my
my producer michael was just telling me
that right now
it's the 40th anniversary of empire
strikes back came out in 1980
and they're putting it in theaters right
now and he said his cousin went
and there were six people in the theater
and it was only eight dollars a ticket
and they give you free popcorn it's like
this is not
sustainable this is absolutely not
sustainable so i don't know what they're
gonna do but
uh let's let's throw this image of some
of the movies that are delayed right now
uh dune is gonna be delayed until
october 2021 the kingsman
until february 2021 ghostbusters
afterlife by the way that's the original
cast of the ghostbusters it's not
the uh the all-girl remake and not to
mansplain but that thing
sucked balls that that sounded like
mansplaining but it wasn't
that the movie just sucked it just was
not funny this is
uh going to be with um you know bill
murray and dan
aykroyd etc that will come out in march
of 2021 no time to die which is the next
bond movie
april 2021 a quiet place part two
april 2021 that's gonna be a big month
apparently black widow
uh may 2021 and then the interesting one
is wonder woman 1984 is going to be
direct on demand i don't have the date
on that but that is kind of interesting
because i
think it was supposed to come out this
summer i think it was originally coming
out maybe in june and then they delayed
it to august and they're going to try
this thing
direct on demand i have a feeling it's
going to absolutely crush it
and if it does crush it right like
because everybody's home trying to find
things to watch like there's just
nothing left i started watching kobrakai
on uh on netflix which is actually
pretty good like they somehow figured
out how to take karate
kid and just like remake it in a way
that like actually feels fun and
self-aware and not and it's cheesy but
not ridiculous anyway
um everyone's trying to find things to
watch and i'm sure you guys are going
through this too you go on itunes and
you're looking
at what's new and it's just all like
b-movie crap
and then they randomly throw in other
things that the algorithm just wants you
to watch they just push it up there for
you
and like everyone's out of things to
watch we're just all watching things
that we've seen already
so the idea that wonder woman is going
to come out it's like everybody at home
that weekend
is going to go okay i'll buy it for
let's say they charge 19.99 or something
and it's like if 5 million people do
that
and it costs 20 bucks well now they've
got 100 million bucks now i don't know
how much they
intend on doing that 5 million people by
the way would be a very low number for
people to see the movie because then
you know the problem with buying the
movie is that if you go to a theater
with a family
you know it's 12 bucks a ticket you got
five people you're at 60 bucks something
like that
but now if you can do it at home you've
tried it's one time fee of 19.99
five people are there or you can invite
other people over so they're gonna have
to figure out i mean i feel like it's a
little bit of a test
of the economics like they're just
testing out okay can we release big
things at home
can they actually work how much money
are we gonna make how much money are we
gonna lose
but beyond that i mean just this idea
it's like going to the movies
is is one of the prime things where we
get to be people with each other
like we don't have a lot of things
anymore because of the way we're trapped
online where we can have like a communal
experience
with somebody i mean you guys know i was
very frustrated with the the last series
of star wars but going to the theater
and being there with the people when
they're
you know laughing when they're crying
when they're you know just whatever that
emotion is forget star wars when you
when you go to a movie that you have
some sort of reaction and being in a
room with people when you feel that you
feel the silence like
we're losing all of those things and and
we need those communal spaces which you
know yesterday i talked about the nba
ratings crashing
and it's like we need those things to be
able to go to a basketball game to be
able to go to a
movie theater to escape politics to
realize that you're with other human
beings to look at
people and see that they can smile
instead of wearing a mask on their face
like we
were losing something the good old days
are basically january
and and something seems very wrong about
that and we got to figure it out
anyway people that is the direct message
for today
october 8th 2020 uh
i did all the mansplaining i can do but
maybe i'll do a little more mansplaining
later i
we have girls coming over later tonight
and i'm gonna talk to them
and treat them as equals and and we'll
see how it goes should i think i think
it's gonna be okay i'm gonna do the
cooking
actually so there's your mansplaining
for you anyway
thanks for watching everybody and we'll
be back on tuesday